all right so news today though and it's
kind of an exciting day here at the
ballpark alec bone has had his contract
selected and is in the starting lineup
tonight playing third base
they'll face right header jake garrieta
coming off an excellent start his last
timeout overall one and one an
unrun average of 2.45
405 start rain delay looks like the
weather
is good in philadelphia and away we go
first pitch hitting base hit hancer
alberto he does not take long to go to
work alberto leads the american league
and multi-hit games is tied for third
with three hit games extra base hits uh
just run down the list here's anton
darren from the left
over toward third caught by bowm fires
to first in time
alberto looked like he slipped as he
throws dirt back to that area and for
jake arrieta that is a sweet double play
the right-hander thomas eshelman
he's been pretty solid this year relief
appearance one start doesn't have a
record yet a very good 3.6 era brings
gene segura to the plate 1-2 pitch
got him on strikes down swinging segura
two down
ruiz do up against jake arietta 3-2
pitch
swinging i missed he struck him out
as jake arrieta strikes out rio ruiz
just in the strikeout basketball by it
and now with bone making his major
league debut
it's that one sharply a base hit down
the left field on his first major league
hit and he's hunting for extra bases
and ball pulls into second with a two
out double
way to get it out of the way on your
first at-bats
big leagues are so easy congratulations
something they will never ever forget
three with a run scored so far in this
series for felika
back toward the middle right at segura
flips to gregorius for one spins and
throws in time a 4-6-3 double play
second double play of the day
here's roman quinn quinn oh for six in
the series
that one's lined to right field that'll
be in for a base hit it's dying in the
grass but roman is on his way to second
and will get there easily standing good
looking swing
three three over leaves up
two two pitch
swing gonna miss he got him 12
consecutive scoreless innings for jake
arrieta that's his third strikeout of
the afternoon eshelman set to face bryce
harper who will lead off for the
phillies here in the fourth and the
pitch swaying in a line drive toward
left center field on the run as hayes
back he goes he looks up and it's off
the wall and in play harper on his way
into second base as hayes gets the ball
back in stand up double for bryce harper
and the phillies have a laid off been on
their third double of the game already
philly's a good chance here with the
runner in scoring position nobody out j
t real muto
out to right center field on the run is
hayes it is gone
two run opposite field home run for jt
real muto
and the phillies take a two nothing lead
here in the bottom of the fourth
what a swing what did it back my jt
that look on his face like you're not
gonna get me again
and here's dwight smith jr
swinging to miss
one out here in the fifth inning i'll
just go with a change up where the
bottom falls out of it
austin hayes fly to right his first time
to the plate
opposite way that's in for a base hit
fielded on a hop by harper
and they will hold nunes so three hits
in this inning with one out
and it brings valencia up with the
phillies are hoping they can entice into
heading into a second double play
back toward the middle right between his
legs diving stops segora flips to second
for one over to first not in time a run
scores oh man what a play
it's truly remarkable
all the way around right through the
wickets of arietta
excellent effort by gene and an
excellent toss
how those guys made it
that close santander now the base is
loaded steps in 2-1
ripped way back
and over the head of the right fielder
harper this could empty the bags
two runs in
here comes the throw to the plate in the
orioles
three run rbi double from anthony
santander three balls two strikes short
lead at first
and a line drive out to right center
field that'll drop for a hit ruiz round
second heads to third the throw by roman
quinn on one hop he is out at third base
what a throw
don't you dare run on me
if that stands that'll be his second
outfield assist of the year and it was
perfectly thrown
here's iglesias
well hit
way back and off the top of the wall
this should score two
jose iglesias jumped all over that pitch
just missed a home run but he drives in
two more and the orioles are up six to
two this kid comes in two eye nobody
down that's not exactly
a piece of cake right
tough situation inherit
severino has two hits in the game steps
in
all enthusiasm and that's hit hard
his first pitch in the major leagues is
gone
a three run shot from pedro severino and
the orioles have plenty of breathing
room now up nine to two
rio one for four
well hit right field
harper running out of room
and he can't get it it's out rio ruiz
dials long distance and the orioles make
it an 11-4 game